Creating photo-realistic materials for light transport algorithms requires carefully fine-tuning a set of material properties
To achieve a desired artistic effect
This is a lengthy process that involves a trained artist with specialized knowledge
In this work we propose a system that only requires basic image processing knowledge
and enables users without photo-realistic rendering experience to create high quality materials
This is highly desirable as human thinking is inherently visual and not based on physically based material parameters
In our proposed workflow All the user needs to do is apply a few intuitive transforms to a source image
and in the next step our technique produces the closest photo-realistic material that approximates this target image
One of our key observations is that even though this process target image is often not physically achievable
in many cases a photo-realistic material model can be found that closely matches this image
Our method generates results in less than 30 seconds and works in the presence of poorly edited target images
Like the discoloration of the pedestal or the background of the gold material here
This technique is especially useful early in the material design
Process where the artist seeks to rapidly iterate over a variety of possible artistic effects
We also proposed an extension to predict image sequences with a tight budget of one to two seconds per image
To achieve this we propose a simple optimization formulation that is able to produce
Accurate solutions but takes relatively long due to the lack of a useful initial guess
our other main observation is that an approximate solution can also be achieved without an
Optimization step by implementing a simple encoder neural network the main advantage of this method. Is that it?
produces a solution within a few milliseconds with the drawback that the provided solution is only
Approximate we refer to this as the inversion technique both of these solutions
suffer from drawbacks the optimization approach provides results that resemble the target image but is
Impracticable due to the fact that it requires too many function evaluations and get stuck in local minima
Whereas the inversion technique rapidly produces a solution, but is more approximate in nature
We show that the best aspects of these two solutions can be fused together
into a hybrid method that initializes our optimizer with the prediction of the neural network this hybrid method opens up the
Possibility of creating novel materials by stitching together the best aspects of two or more materials
Deleting unwanted features through image in painting contrast enhancement or even fusing together two materials
These synthesized materials can also be easily inserted into already existing scenes by the user
In this scene we made a material mixture to achieve a richer Nebula effect inside the glass
We also show in the paper that this hybrid method not only gives a head start to the
Optimizer by endowing it with a useful initial guess but provides strictly higher quality outputs than any of the two previous
solutions on all of our test cases
Furthermore if at most a handful of materials are sought the total modelling times reveal that our technique compares
favorably to previous work on mascara material synthesis
We believe this method will offer an appealing entry point for novices into the world of photorealistic material modeling
Thank you for your attention